today's video is sponsored by nordpass
create and store your passwords easily
and securely with the cyber security
experts from nordvpn more on them in a bit
picture this you're 50 000 feet in the air it
controls an experimental tiny rocket-powered
airplane designed for one purpose to fly as fast
as it possibly can your mission is to do something
no human being has ever done before and you know
that any number of things one small mistake a tiny
flaw in the plane's design bad luck or the whims
of fate could conspire to lead to your sudden and
very violent death most people would say you'd be
crazy to even consider doing such a thing but then
most people aren't chuck yeager over a career
that spans seven decades jaeger became one of
america's most famous aviators primarily known
for his feat of being the first pilot to fly
faster than the speed of sound in 1947 but
chuck jaeger was so much more than that one
admittedly awe-inspiring flight he was also a war
hero but a trailblazing test pilot who helped to
expand our knowledge of the way aircraft
behaved at high speeds and high altitudes
a critical foundation for mankind's ascent
into space he also transcended the cockpit
to become a cultural icon with books and movies
being made about his deeds we'll tell you today
about chuck yeager's extraordinary life
and hopefully we won't go too fast for you
charles el rodriguez was born on february 13 1923
on a farm in rural west virginia chuck did
want to be a farmer so with few other options
available he joined the army a few months after
graduating from high school in 1941 originally
enlisted aircraft mechanic the outbreak of world
war ii provided the catalyst for his advancement
as he was accepted into flight school and
commissioned as an officer sent to europe
jaeger flew p-51 mustang fighters and participated
in deadly aerial duels with the german luftwaffe
in march 1944 his airplane was shot down
over occupied france and he spent three weeks
behind enemy lines before escaping to neutral
spain with the help of the french resistance
returning to england jaeger protested against
a policy that prohibited him from flying over
enemy territory since he had already been shot
down once and had been helped by the resistance
after an appeal to supreme allied commander
general dwight d eisenhower jaeger was given
permission to resume flying jaeger would go on
to see more combat including a memorable occasion
when he became an ace in a day being credited
with downing five aircraft on a single mission
he ended the war with 11.5 aerial victories on his
tally as well as both the silver and bronze stars
and the distinguished flying cross he had his
pick of assignments when he returned to the us
but instead of getting himself some cushy desk
job jaeger got himself involved in work that
was arguably more dangerous than anything
he'd seen in the war he became a test pilot
the post-war world was one of remarkable
scientific advancement in all fields but
particularly in aviation as the us military tapped
the knowledge of german scientists captured at the
end of the conflict in europe nazi germany had
been at the forefront of aviation technology
including the first operational jet-powered
fighter and rudimentary ballistic missiles and
the united states wanted to incorporate
that knowledge for itself especially
once it found out that the soviet union was
doing the same thing to create aircraft that
could fly faster and higher than anything ever
seen before the military needed to test various
designs in the air most of this testing was
conducted at moroccan army airfield in the
mojave desert of california today called edwards
air force base the pilot stationed at morocc
were an eclectic bunch and with good reason
being a test pilot was exceedingly dangerous
on average each pilot had a 53 chance of
being killed in the line of duty meaning
that each man brave enough to climb into
one of these experimental planes knew
that they were taking their life into their hands
each time they went up among this group of pilots
was 24 year old chuck yeager he was considered
one of the best which is why i was selected for
one of the most important test flights in aviation
history up to that point aircraft designers had
been unable to design a plane that was capable
of breaking the so-called sound barrier firing
faster than the speed of sound approximately 750
miles per hour the stresses placed on both pilot
and plane as they approached mach 1 were enormous
and even if the airframe survived without tearing
itself apart it was not uncommon for a pilot
going that fast to lose control and crash
which usually meant certain death in 1947 the
united states air force believed that it had a
plane that could break the sound barrier the bell
x-1 a state-of-the-art rocket-powered plane that
was designed to be dropped from a modified b-29
bomber at altitude to save fuel but who would be
brave enough or crazy enough to fly it not top
bell aircraft pilot slick goodlin who refused
to make an attempt on the sound barrier unless he
was paid a king's ransom of 150 thousand dollars
the equivalent of 1.75 million today the military
turned to jaeger who agreed to go for it on the
14th of october 1947 chuck yeager strapped into
the x1 that had christened a glamorous glennis
after his wife preparing to fly faster than any
man had ever gone before in a tiny plane painted
bright orange to make it more visible to observers
on the ground what he hadn't told anyone was
that two days before the flight had fallen while
horseback riding and broken two ribs he concealed
the injury from the air force so wouldn't be
pulled from the mission the pain was so bad that
he needed to use a broom handle to secure the x1's
hatch since she couldn't reach it by hand when
the b-29 mother ship reached an altitude of 45
thousand feet jaeger's plane was dropped from it
and he activated the engine shooting off across
the southern california sky faster and faster he
flew calling out his progress over the radio mach
.97.98.99 and then ground observers heard a loud
bang exploding across the desert everyone assumed
jaeger had crashed and feared the worst for the
young pilot but what they'd heard was actually
a sound unfamiliar to their ears a sonic boom
an extremely loud shock wave that occurs when
an aircraft reaches a speed faster than the
speed of sound he'd done it by the time the x1
landed safely chuck yeager was a national hero
the first recorded supersonic man alright we'll
get back to today's video in just a second but
first here's a quick word from today's great
video sponsor nord pass nordpass is a next
generation password manager where cyber security
meets modern convenience how many times have you
struggled to remember those passwords you only
use once or twice a year suddenly trying to
reset a password and you can't remember the name
of your first grade teacher before you know it
half an afternoon is gone nordpass is the perfect
solution to your password management problems
installs all of your login and credit card
information in one super secure password vault
letting you autofill any login with just a single
click but nordpass isn't just a one-trick pony its
password health feature analyzes your passwords
letting you know if they're too old too weak or
being used across too many websites if they are
you can use its password generation tool to create
and store new more secure passwords and if that's
not enough it's also got a data breach scanner a
cool nordpass tool lets you know if your login or
credit card information has been leaked somewhere
online and of course it's all designed and managed
by the same experts who run nordvpn so you know
they've got that proven track record of internet
security right now you guys can get 70 off a
two-year nordpass premium plan at nordpass.com
forward slash biographics or use the code
biographics at checkout plus you get an additional
month for free wonderful now back to today's video
again rather than resting on his laurels he
continued to fly dangerous and important test
flights for the air force in 1953 set a new speed
record when his upgraded x1a aircraft reached a
speed of back 2.44 granted almost immediately
afterwards he lost control of his plane and
dropped over 50 000 feet in less than a minute but
he was able to recover and land without further
incident and as the aviation saying goes any
landing you walk away from is a good one after a
stint commanding squadrons of fighter jets in 1962
jager was given a promotion to colonel and a new
assignment the first commandant of the usaf air
force research pilot school which was given the
responsibility for training something totally new
astronauts jaeger and the other test pilots worked
on high speed high altitude flights and helped
pave the way for sending men into outer space
and with many people considering jaeger to
be one of the air force's most outstanding
pilots it seemed only fitting that he'd be
put in charge of training america's best to
eventually send them to space from the outside
it might seem strange that someone as experienced
as jaeger was wasn't selected himself to become an
astronaut jaeger was the same age as alan shepard
the first american in space and had far more
experience as both a test pilot and a combat
aviator but the key difference between them was
that shepard had graduated from the united states
naval academy while jaeger had never progressed
past a high school education and had started off
his career as an enlisted man nasa and the u.s
government only wanted college graduates in the
astronaut core as part of the carefully cultivated
public image that they were creating around the
space program being made up of america's best and
brightest for his part jaeger never appeared to be
bothered about not being asked to go to space
in his autobiography he essentially claimed
astronauts were more glorified lab rats the
actual pilots calling them essentially passengers
thrown the right switches on instructions from the
ground still there's no way to know for sure if
jager would have taken them up on the offer if it
had been extended eventually the decision was made
to make nasa an entirely civilian run agency and
responsibility for training astronaut candidates
was taken away from the military branches still 26
men trained by jaeger went on to become astronauts
including frank borman commander of the apollo
8 mission that was the first to orbit the moon
and michael collins the pilot of the apollo 11
mission where neil armstrong became the first man
to walk on the moon's surface in one instance
however jaeger found himself at the center of
a controversy about who wasn't selected to be an
astronaut rather than who was according to jaeger
he was forced by air force chief of staff curtis
lemay to increase the size of his class program
so that a black candidate ed dwight was included
lamay told jaeger that he was receiving pressure
from the kennedy white house on the subject
and jaeger had no choice but to acquiesce
dwight was ultimately not selected to become an
astronaut despite a massive publicity campaign
surrounding his candidacy which dwight blamed
on racial discrimination in his autobiography
dwight intensity faced bigotry and prejudice
from jaeger and the other instructors at
arps while he was enrolled there and that they
did everything in their power to force him to fail
out of pure racism jaeger on the other hand
argued that while he and his instructors felt
resentful that dwight had been shoved down their
throats for political reasons he treated dwight as
barely as he did every other student and that the
reason he struggled was because he wasn't as good
of a pilot as the other students were the truth as
usual probably lies somewhere in the middle dwight
probably did face racial bigotry while enrolled
at arps an unfortunately common occurrence
considering the racist attitudes prevalent at the
time however there is virtually no evidence beyond
dwight's own accounts that jaeger himself was a
racist or behaved discriminately towards black
people and in any case jaeger had no control
over who nasa did or didn't pick to join it
to astronaut corps anyway gion bluford would
eventually become the first african american
to go into space 20 years later in 1983 aboard
space shuttle challenger december 1963 jaeger's
test flying career came to an abrupt end when
the nf-104 jetty was piloting went dead stick
losing complete control and entering a flat spin
after losing 95 000 feet of altitude diego decided
the aircraft was unrecoverable and triggered the
ejection seat before he could fully separate from
his ejection seat the white hot rocket motor
struck him in the face shattering his helmet
visor and scenting his emergency oxygen supply
on fire yeah suffered serious burns to his face
which required a long and painful recovery process
after this near-death experience jaeger decided to
test flying and setting records was a younger
man's game that didn't mean that he took his
foot off the accelerator however in 1966 he was
given command of a fighter squadron and command
admissions over south vietnam as that conflict
was heating up flying the f-4 phantom fighter in
1969 he was promoted to brigadier general and
made the vice commander of the 17th air force
stationed in west germany he would later go on to
serve as a diplomatic advisor to the pakistani air
force putting him at the center of a potential
diplomatic incident when the passenger plane
assigned to him was destroyed during an air
raid by the indian air force during the 1971
indo-pakistani war yeager rage show anyone that
would listen that indira gandhi had ordered his
plane destroyed to give uncle sam the finger in
1975 after a 33-year career general jaeger retired
from the air force his fame as a pilot had long
ago been eclipsed by that of the astronauts and
he might have faded into a relative historical
footnote where not for the publication of a book
called the right stuff in 1979 by author and
journalist tom wolf in the book woolf shows
that the achievements of the mercury seven the
original men picked to be astronauts by nasa
would not have gotten off the ground were not for
the groundwork laid by test pilots such as chuck
yeager the best-selling book was adapted into a
film in 1983 with sam shepard portraying jaeger
on screen jaeger himself appeared in a cameo role
in the critically acclaimed film which introduced
his name and deeds to a whole new generation of
americans probably never heard of him jaeger's
newfound popularity found him thrust back into
the public in a variety of ways his autobiography
published in 1985 was a bestseller so were a
series of video games published by electronic arts
that featured jaeger's name and likeness and that
he served as a technical advisor on he was twice
invited to drive the pace car for the indianapolis
500 and he appeared in a series of television
advertisements for auto parts company ac delco
on a more somber note jaeger was appointed by
president reagan to the rogers commission which
investigated the catastrophic destruction of
the space shuttle challenger in january 1986
during a launch watched by millions of people
on live tv the explosion just 73 seconds into
the flight killed all seven astronauts on board
including new hampshire school teacher christa
mcauliffe mcauliffe was supposed to be the first
ordinary person in space the focus of a massive
publicity campaign that now had turned to disaster
over the course of four months jaeger and the
rest of the commission including former astronauts
neil armstrong and sally ride held hearings and
collected evidence to uncover what went wrong the
commission found that a critical part inside one
of the boost rockets failed because of freezing
cold weather at the site on the day of launch
this allowed a jet of white hot burning gas to
leak out of the side of the rocket punching
a hole in the external fuel tank and igniting
the contents blowing the entire shuttle apart the
commission's report was highly critical of nasa's
leadership for ignoring warnings from engineers
and prioritizing their launch over safety
jaeger's post-retirement years were largely spent
in comfort having amassed a sizable fortune from
book royalties endorsement contracts and speaking
engagements jaeger lived with his wife glenis in
northern california until she died of ovarian
cancer in 1990 after 45 years of marriage the
couple had raised four children together two
of which followed in their father's footsteps
with long careers in the air force retirement
didn't put a damper on the old test pilot's
thirst for speed however on the 50th anniversary
of jaeger's historic mach 1 flight in 1997 jaeger
once again broke the sound barrier piloting an
f15 fighter jet you think that's incredible just
considered this wasn't even the last time he'd
do this 15 years later at the eye-popping age
of 89 yeager did it again though on this flight
he consented to make the flight as a passenger
the very fact that an 89 year old man would
subject himself to the rigors of supersonic flight
says a lot about his character not the jaeger's
golden years were free from controversy however
in 2000 the 77 year old flying ace met and fell
in love with victoria de angelo an actress 35
years as junior in 2003 they married in a private
ceremony the match caused a rift between jaeger
and his children who believed that victoria
had only married their father for his money
a lawsuit was filed and then a counter suit and
the litigation dragged on for years in the end the
court sided with jaeger against his children and
jaeger would tell reporters that he didn't care
what his children thought about his life choices
he was going to do whatever he wanted to be happy
on december 7 2020 chuck yeager died in los
angeles hospital at the age of 97. the death of
this american hero touched off a wave of mourning
nationwide his body was flown aboard air force two
the vice president of the united states plane
to charleston west virginia where he was buried
with full military honours in a ceremony that took
place on january the 15th 2021 jaeger was so well
respected that his funeral briefly brought both
republican and democratic politicians together
to pay their respects often called america's
greatest pilot chuck yeager represents the
bridge between the rough and tumble aerial cowboys
that typified the fighter pilots of the two world
wars with the highly educated technology savvy
professionals that pilot today's modern machines
though described by tom wolf as having the right
stuff the combination of guts and daring needed
to do things like break the sound barrier and
take other risks jaeger himself disputed that
he said that his skill in the cockpit could
be attributed to his exceptional vision a
thorough knowledge of his airplane and how
it operated and more than a little good luck
in any case his contributions to aviation will
long be remembered not only by historians but
by military officers space enthusiasts or by
anybody who watches the books and films made
about his life and achievements not bad
for a humble farm boy from west virginia
you